i thought i've got the nurse girl the
weatherman said it's cloudy skies right
there between your thighs
i want it soaking wet all over the bed
can you sing these lyrics she wrote them
hey man
serena in a mini skirt is is crazy i
mean one leg is like the it's me like
one leg yeah this is her whole leg right
here
[Applause]
[Laughter]
killing l.a and i get to my mike tyson
joke and that's where i usually get a
standing ovation and when i get to the
joke
nobody laughs cause mike tyson is in the
building
and i get to that joke and somebody else
mike is in here
and then it was a black girl and you
know there's a black girl egging on
she's sitting in the front what you're
gonna do jamie you're gonna tell your
little joke
yo i want you to go to read for for tc
in new york i said who tc
all right
tom cruise and all the old time crew so
i go to read but as i'm reading
i'm loud show me the money
you know what i mean right that's all
i'm saying brother show me the money
rick james came in and broke my bed
i i had like like in my room it was some
girl hanging out with her laying on the
bed and he just runs hey damn i love the
house boom broke the bed
i was like ricky just broke one you can
buy another damn bed get another bag
tom cruise reads his line but it was
like this
so i thought he lost his place
because i couldn't hear himself he says
i know i set the line and waiting on you
i'm like oh
i don't know if it's our culture but
your your butt your ass sticks out a
little more because my pops i used to
watch my pops when he would come home
and it was this
[Applause]
and i was like pops what is that you
keep on living keep on living
i mean
yo buy the damn cookies
[Applause]
[Music]
i think at that time i was the only
black dude
doing um a ronald reagan impersonation
which i think you might still be the
only black dude
but i would go on like well well as a
matter of fact i would put there you go
again so i mean i had all of these
different you know the way
all right
all right
and then the way michael mann shoots the
film there were points to where we would
do 53-minute takes
meaning that we would just drive the k
well they weren't they were pulling the
cab oh they're pulling it you know i
wouldn't actually drop but then
sometimes i'll forget and be doing my
lines like yeah man you know the crazy
thing about it
you did dave chappelle in the show i
don't think crazy i was excited myself i
was inspired
but that but that's the that's the young
chappelle too i was cr that was incensed
i was beside myself somebody walked up
and said dave chappelle pow
but the oldest appeal is crazy i was uh
from hbo they took all my money so don't
watch hvac
took all my money so please
please guys it was
took all of it
you hear what i'm saying man
you're hearing me
it took all my money
he was so
you know what i'm talking about i saw
that video yeah dave was so convincingly
broke
that i wanted to start a gofundme page
for this dude
it was crazy man they took they took all
of the money i was like they did
wait a minute he just flew there on this
g650
just got paid 60 millions or something
right does they like oh man does they
like when you imitate what i'm saying
all of my
[Laughter]
that is good i'm like almost 50. so i
was going to i went to i hate going to a
club in l.a because i was going to uh
1-0 and uh these girls pull up and i'm
outside the club i'm about to go in the
girls [ __ ] oh my god jamie fox i'm like
what's up
we go to school with your daughter
are you going in the club no it's a it's
a open house but i'm gonna go see
well you worked with al pacino yeah
al pacino yeah absolutely
ah
what did you what's it like to have
what's it like to have fingernails
when did he start doing that i don't
know he he changed at some point
you know he was fredo alfredo don't ever
go into his family again you heard me
friday friday and then all of a sudden
ah
this club these girls was by the dj
booth and they were just so young like i
said well how are these i'm 22.
howdy i'm 23.
oh my gosh she's ancient she's 27 i'm
like wow then the girl asked me how old
i was when i told him how old i was you
would have thought that i told him i had
a terminal disease
well i'm 49 oh my god
what kind of a dad are you i'm a tough
dad until it actually comes down to it
right i know what you mean you know what
i'm saying i wish he would i wish he
would bring a dude and i'm gonna blow
his head off i'm gonna just i'm gonna
kill him i'm gonna kill him i'mma kill
him and he shows up i'm like hey brother
how you doing
[Music]
i was a comic in l.a so back at that
time it wasn't on instagram right in
order for you to see a celebrity you had
to get into hollywood and brock's you
know roxbury sure yeah so i would just
stand on the other side of roxbury
because they wouldn't let me uh on that
side because i had no i'm saying yeah
get over that man ain't your club dog
so i was standing on the other side and
everybody that would walk out
i know he didn't remember this but
wesley snipes
i would stalk wesley snipes and i was a
dude on the other side of the street
when they walk out westley snipes
i see you west last night
west and every week i was there and then
one day
denzel washington okay walked out that
joint and i sprinted across i went i
reached security right and you know and
when he walked out you know when black
people get excited we march
like i said i was like oh denzel
[Applause]
him and he did some kind of denzel move
like hold on all right okay all right
just hold on it stuck me right in the
neck i'm like i'm just trying to give
you your pride
i love your dick
you know what i remember i did i did
dave chappelle pause i did an
impersonation of dave chappelle in front
of dave chappelle at eddie's house oh
yeah that night that party and murphy's
house that's right go to eddie's house
which is crazy so all of us all the
comedians rock i'm glad you thought it
was crazy because i was just like i
don't know what the hell i'm doing here
but i can't believe i'm here it's crazy
right yes i mean you're just waiting on
eddie to just come out you know from the
balcony and just suckle me comedian
no i was waiting on like the scene from
gladiator you know
what was the dude i will give you comedy
beyond your riches
i'll just wait you know do that right
but eddie i remember that night because
eddie was talking about going out and
doing stand-up mm-hmm and i was looking
at his house i'm like you can't do
stand-up
with with the way this house is
because the house was so perfect
you know it's like you can't have a
perfect house like my house my house
stays sort of messed up because i want
to stay funny like you know i've never i
never finished decorating all the way
there's a faucet in this one bathroom
that sprays out
and when i stand i stand in the hallway
to see people come out because you just
and people come out
but at the end of the night everybody
was trying to win funnier funniest of
the night you started circling around 2
30 whatever i didn't even try i was just
standing in the corner
but at one point
was standing rock eddie everybody and
dave says
look at jamie's shoes i said what about
my shoes
he said what i said what
and i was like man it's crazy look at
jamie's shooting i started saying yes
james my shoes dave
crazy and then he goes man this is wild
man jamie is doing impersonation i mean
this is wow and then eddie is sitting
there going like
and there's something about channing
tatum's name i just you know i like that
channing
tatum it just sounds you know it sounds
amazing so we did a song to it called
chanting all over your tatum
and it
scanning all over your chain all over
your table
and this
and the song you know i took a little
bit of uh we we did it on another show
but i took a little bit of of of of of
benny and the jets sure and sort of
changed up jenny hold on hold up right
there if you're gonna do it
here
[Applause]
channing olivia
trinny
jenny
love is so dramatic she likes to sing
into my mind because my mic is
[Applause]